it's fun in the sun in the resort city
of cancun
but mexican health officials say a boom
in international tourism has also led to
a significant rise in covid19 infections
a warning that doesn't seem to be much
of a bother to foreign tourists
so far we haven't felt exposed there are
protocols in place and we've been
wearing our masks and everything
following the rules and washing our
hands vacation hot spots aren't the only
places where contagion is on the rise
in mexico city a sharp increase in cases
has also led to higher turnout at
vaccination sites
concern is also spreading among parents
as millions of children return to school
from the holiday break
we have to be very careful because this
is affecting the children more than
before so we need to have more safety
measures but with the support of us all
and the teachers we should be all right
more than four million cases of covet 19
have been recorded in mexico since the
start of the pandemic according to data
from johns hopkins university and deaths
from the virus have surpassed 300
thousand
with such a staggering death toll the
government has been accused of
negligence in its handling of the
pandemic response
and despite a steep rise in new cases
mexico's president has denied the
country has entered a fourth wave of
contagion
yes this new variant is very contagious
but luckily it is not requiring
hospitalizations
nor have we registered an increase in
the number of deaths and that is the
most important thing
mexico's government has not yet released
official numbers of infections linked to
the omicron
variant policy analysts say this isn't
the only area where transparency is
lacking
one thing that we still don't have in
mexico and it would be very important
for the health ministry to publish is a
database on the progress of the
vaccination campaign we have daily
reports yes but we don't have the
database that can be analyzed
mexico's government continues to face
criticisms over what many see as a
relaxed attitude toward contagion
and for not requiring a negative covet
19 test for foreign visitors
this recent surge in coronavirus cases
is not limited to mexico but rather a
trend being experienced by countries all
across latin america manuel rapalo al
jazeera mexico city